all right up next is gonna be Sheree in
Indiana hi Sheree how are you holidays
I'm fine how are you
better than I deserve what's up well I
am 56 years old and I'm an empty nester
now but gotta kick through college but
we hung cries we did not play for their
college fund and so once they got into
school they get out some student loans
they still came up short for tuition and
the Registrar's Office was crazy thing
about a Parent PLUS loan so yes so we
took out our clowns hold those my
children and what we do not realize is
they gave us the option to give her
payment so for the six years that they
clearly were in college we defer the
payment not realizing that deferring the
payments not paying even on the interest
that that interest is going to roll over
to the balance the following parents and
so by the time that we got them through
college
we now have eighty thousand dollars
worth of debt and can't press bones and
so then they contact us because the last
one is now done so of course now it's
time to start home box so for my
convenience we're going to set me up
with a 30-year loan at six hundred and
three dollars a month and by that time
I'm going to be 86 years old so I did
the math and still be here 33 160 months
at three hundred or six hundred and
three dollars there's two hundred
seventeen thousand dollars that I'm
going to be paying back are you so you
keep saying we you and your husband my
husband and I yes okay and what is your
household income at 56 years our 52
years old
well 56 to 58 okay what's your household
income $77,000 okay both of you
working 40 hours I was a part-time
teacher but medical reasons I am now not
working what are the what is the nature
of your medical problems I have
neuropathy in my legs and with edema
swelling so now we have also medical
bills on top of it okay what's your
husband do for a living he works at a
car manufacturing plant engineer okay as
an engineer yes an engineer apartment
okay because here's what I'm thinking
number one we're not going to do a 30
year plan so far everything these people
have suggested to you has hurt you so I
don't think were gonna use them for
suggestions for anything what I would
rather do is pay off $40,000 a year for
two years which would mean that you
would probably be doing some teaching
some tutoring that you could do
depending on your health from your home
at 25 or 30 dollars an hour as much of
it as you can possibly do with your
health condition and he's going to be
looking for extra work or overtime and
you guys are gonna work like maniacs
because you have made a huge mess and
this thing is going to ride you into the
grave if you don't punch it in the face
hard when we do not realize that you
can't get a look like a personal world
no you don't need a personal loan you
have an $80,000 Parent PLUS loan at an
interest rate that it's better than you
can get on a bank loan so you have a
$40,000 a year problem for two years and
it's gone that's a $3,200 a month and
that means you're gonna be living on
nothing you're gonna stop all retirement
savings you're not gonna see the inside
of a restaurant unless you're working
there you're not going on vacation and
you're gonna lean in with great focused
intensity okay if we want to do it over
three years what would it be
thirty thousand twenty five hundred
dollars a month but somewhere
north of 2000 hopefully north of $3,000
a month is going on this because extreme
measures are going to be taken in your
household to get your income up and your
expenses down in order to do that
otherwise this thing's gonna ride you to
death into the grave it's killing you
it's unbelievable and this is the
debacle that is the student loan
industry this is the epic plague that is
the student loan industry